members of Congress hammered Facebook
CEO Mark Zuckerberg in his final day of
testimony on Capitol Hill he answered a
wide variety of questions from members
of the House Energy and Commerce
Committee yesterday Zuckerberg was
questioned for about 10 hours over two
days about his company's failure to
protect user data chip Reid is on
Capitol Hill chip good morning good
morning the questioning in the house was
more aggressive than it was Tuesday in
the Senate but Zuckerberg remained calm
and deferential he also revealed for the
first time that he was one of the 87
million whose personal information was
harvested by Cambridge analytical with
your data included in the data sold to
the malicious third parties your
personal data yes lawmakers peppered
Mark Zuckerberg with a wide range of
questions especially on Facebook's
willingness to protect user data you are
collecting personal information on
people who do not even have Facebook
accounts isn't that right I don't think
that that's what we're tracking there
was a tremendous bias against
conservative news and content and a
favorable bias towards liberal content
there is absolutely no directive and any
of the changes that we make to have a
bias and anything that we do are you
willing to change your business model in
the interest of protecting individual
privacy
congresswoman we are have made and are
continuing to make changes to reduce the
amount about are you willing to change
your business model in the interest of
protecting individual privacy
congresswoman I'm not sure what that
means the number of issues reflects the
unprecedented amount of global power
that Facebook actually has Tristan
Harris of the Center for Humane
Technology thinks the fundamental
problem is Facebook's business model in
2017 Facebook earned nearly 40 billion
dollars in advertising revenue a 49%
increase from the previous year about
one in five dollars spent in online
advertising went to Facebook last year
its business model is to keep people
hooked and to basically make your mind
as influenceable as possible to
advertisers Zuckerberg said he believes
government regulation of social media is
now inevitable and there
some support on both sides of the aisle
but the chances of passing major
legislation in this divisive election
year are slim at best John at best Thank
You chip